is
ra Carby an Iranian climbing Champion
here competing on the world stage but
for the first time without a headscarf a
usual requirement for female athletes
representing the nation
posting on Instagram she apologized for
causing worry and says her hijab
inadvertently came off but those close
to her like zainab a friend and former
teammate are concerned about her welfare
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
of them
the International Federation of sport
climbing is keeping a watchful eye too
saying it is aware of the news it is
important to stress that athlete's
safety is Paramount for us and we
support any efforts to keep a valued
member of our community safe in this
situation the ifsc fully support the
rights of athletes their choices and
expression of free speech
it brings back memories for sure by it
now living in London the Iranian
National fears ever returning home after
being pictured without a headscarf at an
international chess tournament
the first thing that I was at the regime
asked me to do was to publish a public
apology on Instagram and that was the
moment that I decided to stand against
it and not to apologize and say no to
the regime
women in Iran are now in a fifth week of
protests over the death of Master amini
demonstrators are not covering their
hair in a show of support for the 22
year old who died in custody after being
arrested for not wearing her hijab
correctly
after 20 years representing her Nation
around the world Ms rakabi might hope
her apology reassures officials that
this was an accident rather than a
deliberate statement ashnaharin Sky News